so what we use
we date
we're dating
okay so diddy is dating a city girl yo
my amy yeah [ __ ] i'm from the city
the 52 year old mogul confirms his
relationship status with 28 year old
rapper young miami on the first episode
of her revolt podcast show karisha
please at one point during the episode
kareesha who was also known as young
miami and his one half of the rap group
city girls asked diddy about his
relationship status what's your
relationship studies
you miss the egg bag
i'm single
you know
i'm single
but i'm dating i'm just taking my time
my life and although he initially
responds by saying he's single she
restructures her question to ask what we
all really want to know what's going on
between them so what we use
we
date we're dating
we go have
dates
and we're friends
we go to exotic locations
we have great times
we go to strip
clubs i'm gonna take you to church
i love it next up miami asked diddy what
it is specifically that he likes about
her and well his response
because you authentic
you know
you're like one of the realest people i
ever met you know what i'm saying and
you're authentically yourself
and your great mother and you know
a great friend you just have a good time
besides having a good time diddy
explains how he and the rapper connect
on a deeper level i get advice from
kareesha
you know i'm saying kareesha tell me
like you know don't don't be in your
head and
you know just a good friend everybody
that's a friend of yours will tell you
like that you're a great friend
during the convo the mogul also opens up
about his breakup with longtime
girlfriend cassie in 2018 who has since
moved on and started a family
it's hard for me to move on
why was it so hard
oh man
cause i just
you know i just i just didn't want to
let her go
and speaking of letting go the father of
six reveals how he's adjusting to life
after the loss of his late ex kim porter
who died from low bar pneumonia four
years ago he and kim raised four
children together twin daughters jesse
james and delilah christian and quincy
diddy also was a father to daughter
chance and son justin from a previous
relationship losing kimmy was just like
i was a full-time father
going from
you know just being on the road and
stuff to
to like actually
having to raise three girls and never
i've never been in this situation and
you know
i guess god gave me some karma hit me
three times
three times i got three girls turning
16.
well from the looks of it diddy is doing
his best to adjust to full-time
fatherhood in march it caught up with
him and his daughter chance on the
oscar's red carpet where he made it
clear that he was prioritizing some
daddy and daughter time
first of all the biggest thing that's
going on tonight is me bringing my
daughter to this because she's an
aspiring actress and we get to have a
date and i i'm just so excited and i'm
just so stunned
i'm at a loss for word so um i'm blessed
to be here you know we get um i'm
presenting tonight and
um we're gonna have a good time but i'm
like
i'm dealing with daddy emotionally when
she walked out yeah right right what did
you say what did you do
i love it there's gonna have to be some
hard conversations coming up
they know what's up
[Music]
you